- Palm Springs.
I guess you can't have
it called Palm Springs
if you don't have palm trees.
It's Tim Schmoyer, with the hat!
Out first time meeting in person.
Roberto Blake in the house.
Friend of the channel, friend of the book.
About to go on an epic rant.
- It's going to be crazy.
- I'm looking forward.
(upbeat salsa music)
- Morning guys. It is just past
five o'clock in the morning.
I am on my way to a YouTube
conference called Clamour Con
in Palm Springs, California.
And I'm going to take you
guys on my journey with me.
(energetic playful music)
- So Clamour Con is a
YouTube conference that,
I don't know how long
it's been around for,
I was invited to go by Tim Schmoyer
who I have a lot of respect for,
friend of the channel,
done some collabs together.
And I don't usually go to
conferences unless I'm speaking.
Mostly because the main value
of going to a conference
is the networking, and I
don't really enjoy networking.
It's not really something I want to get
better at either, it's
not really on my list.
There's a bunch of people
that I know that are going
who I've virtually met. Like
Tim, like Roberto Blake,
like Antonio. A bunch of
people that I've virtually met
that I know are going, so at
least it's going to be a good time
with them, and we'll see what happens.
It was one of those things where,
I felt like I didn't need to go,
but I may regret not
going so I want to know.
I'm okay with knowing and it failing.
I'm okay with knowing
and it not working out
and being a waste of a couple of days.
What I'm not okay with is
wondering, uhh I should've
gone, what if I went?
So anytime you get that feeling
where you know you might
regret not doing it,
just go out and do it.
You can live with failure,
but you can't live with
the regret of not knowing.
So, that's me. That's Clamour Con.
I'm on my way to Palm Springs.
We'll have some fun.
(lighthearted guitar music)
- Landed in Chicago.
Got to hop my flight now to Palm Springs.
One of the things that I love doing,
on airplanes when I run
out of things to do,
catching up on emails,
is my Evernote file.
So when people send me
articles or I find an article
that I want to read, one
of the things I'll do is
I'll clip it to save it later
and then I'll load it offline in Evernote
and it was good. It was
a bunch of articles that
I haven't read for a while.
I saved up for myself to read
and finally got to check
them off my to do list
so that was fun.
In Chicago it's rainy, but hopefully it's
nice, warm, and sunny in
Palm Springs, California.
(lighthearted guitar music)
- [Evan] So I was on
the fence whether to get
a Starbucks or not. Try to eat healthy,
but then I saw this, frappuccino
new, Midnight Mint Mocha.
I have to try one.
Oh, oh my God it's so good, the mint.
Maybe it's cause I haven't
had frappuccino in a while.
There's no coffee though I
think it's just cream based.
Oh my God the mint.
It's like after eight, in a drink.
Oh my God it's so good.
This isn't in Canada.
I might end up having
one of these a day. Nina's
not going to be happy with me.
- Are you serious?
- But it's really yummy.
(energetic music)
- Alright I made it. Look
what I see when I come out.
It says entrepreneur,
entrepreneur of the year.
I love it. That was actually
a decent trip. I decided to get Wifi
for the first time I
think I would ever order
Wifi from the plane. Usually,
I get on the plane answer my
email, I read my articles,
and then I might have stuff
to do until I watch the movie
and whatever, but today I
decided I'm going to get Wifi
and I was productive
pretty much every single
minute so far of the trip.
I was either at the airport
I was on Instagram just sending messages
to people to thank them for following me.
Ooh look at this, Welcome to Palm Springs.
Look at that, it's beautiful here.
Nice and warm and then on the airplane
I was watching the YouTube videos
prepping for next week,
for all the videos.
Got a lot of work done.
I'm being really hard
on the team this week, I feel bad.
But I feel good because it's for you guys.
The standards are going up
of what kind of clips
make it into the top ten.
Rising standards mean better videos.
So, anyway, I'm feeling
good I feel really didn't
waste a whole bunch of time in the air,
traveling, so I'm going to hop an Uber
and get to the hotel. I'm feeling pumped
it's beautiful, palm trees.
Palm Springs, I guess
you can't have it called
Palm Springs if you don't have palm trees.
Kind of goes together right?
Alright, let's do it.
Exit only, no return. Ha ha!
I have to walk across the street to get to
where Uber is allowed to pick you up
but, it's beautiful here guys.
Look what I see, nice
mountains, palm trees,
water fountain, flowers. Kind
of missing Nina right now.
Should be holding hands,
doing this together.
She has a nine to five job so,
she can only take so much time off.
(inhales deeply)
- I love it.
I'm really glad I took
my allergy medication.
Smell of grass, I'm allergic to grass
but it smells so good.
(enchanted guitar music)
- Alright I made it.
Home for the next couple days.
The Westin, Mission Hills.
Let's go see inside.
(playful guitar music)
- I think I found Tim Schmoyer,
friend of the channel,
YouTuber, done some collabs
I'm going to go surprise him.
It's Tim Schmoyer!
It's Tim Schmoyer, with the hat!
Our first time meeting in person.
- It's good to see you man.
- Well that was good.
Tim and I meet pretty much every week
in an online Mastermind
group that he started
so it's always fun to meet people
in person instead of just
meeting on the computer.
I'm excited. I'm going to go find my room.
(person cheers)
- I need to find my room
and I get checked in.
(energetic salsa music)
- [Evan] 535, casa Carmichael
for the next three days.
Let's put on some lights.
That's pretty nice.
Master bedroom, got some coffee,
look at the bathroom,
looks nice. I approve, going to unpack
and it is what, one thirty right now
and the first reception
pool party intros to people
is at two. So I'm going
to go hang out there.
Tim offered to introduce me to people.
My general strategy with
these kinds of things
is since I don't go up and talk to people,
I will often just bring a
computer, or have my phone
and sit down in a public
place and chill, or work.
And then people recognize me and
come up and start conversations.
So that's my plan! And
we'll see how it goes.
I don't know why, but the first thing I do
when I check into a hotel in
the U.S. is I turn on CNN.
I never watch CNN at
home, I don't know why.
It just feels like I'm traveling.
(laughing)
- And I need to put on
CNN. It's a tradition.
Alright had a shower, changed
my shirt, look at that.
Totally different shirt, right?
You guys can totally tell
it's a different shirt.
Going to go check in. Apparently they have
some other stuff happening.
People are just still starting to arrive
and so, we'll see.
Today's mostly just about
meeting people, connecting,
hanging out by the pool.
If I don't connect with anybody
I'll work on some videos for you guys
and then the conference
actually starts tomorrow.
So, let's check in and see what happens.
I'm here to pick up some SWAG.
Got a tee shirt, got some
cashew almond toffee,
and there's some bugs,
chile lime crickets.
Nina's going to love this.
Are they all crickets?
- [Man] Yeah, all of them.
- Barbecue mealworms, I
don't know about that.
This is Ricky!
- Hey guys.
- Ricky what's up. What's
your favorite video?
- All of them, to be honest.
I mean I wake up every morning
I have my cup of coffee
or my espresso, and you
know, the marketing one,
I just watched the marketing one,
which is why I love to
do this kind of stuff so.
- Love it. Ricky's a YouTuber too.
We're going to chat
afterwards, we're going to chat
after I grab my crickets.
Time to eat, we're at the Seasons Grill.
I don't know if this is
dinner, or lunch, both?
- [Tim] Dinner's at seven,
so this is like lunch.
- [Evan] Dinner's at seven,
I'm chilling with Tim.
And we're on weird time zone differences
we're three hours behind.
So this is lunch okay, what's for lunch?
There it is, chicken fettuccine.
Tim just ordered this crazy,
there's a pineapple inside the burger.
That's crazy.
I'm going to have to come
back and get that next time.
We're going to do a video with
videoinfluencers, here's Sean.
What are we talking about?
- We could talk about entrepreneurship.
We're going to be talking
about your one word.
about online video.
It's going to be crazy.
- I'm looking forward.
- In this video I interview
Evan Carmichael on his tips for
how to stand out on your YouTube channel
through branding, YouTube algorithm hacks,
and how to make more money
on your YouTube channel
through strategic brand deals.
- So far so good, fun event.
Lots of people inside, big YouTubers.
Nobody's really vlogging
or filming so I don't want
to be the douche bag
inside filming everybody.
Next up.
- I didn't want to
video bomb you too much.
- We're going to head back to Tim's room
for a private interview.
For video creators, go check that out.
Actually, when is ours going to go live?
- [Tim] I have no idea.
- Okay this will go live before Tim's so
go check out Tim's channel at
some point for this interview.
- [Tim] It'll be a few weeks at least.
- Couple weeks.
This is Tim's setup,
it's pretty impressive.
- Set it up once and leave
it set up for the whole time.
- [Evan] His camera's bigger than mine,
but it's how you use it.
Look at that, I feel like a winner today.
Yes.
That's how I'm greeted when
I come into Tim's home.
Tim's home.
So it was a fun interview with Tim.
We'll see when it comes out.
Hopefully, that he keeps the bloopers on.
Now there's hors d'oeuvres.
Hors d'oeuvres in the background.
Just basically being up saying hi.
Got some drink tickets. We'll see.
(playful guitar music)
- Definitely got to grab some guacamole.
- Roberto Blake in the
house, friend of the channel,
friend of the book. About
to go on an epic rant.
- Oh God we're doing that.
- [Evan] Epic rant!
- I was talking to Karen.
You got my friend Karen Cabot over here.
- Hey!
- We're actually doing a
panel tomorrow together,
it's going to be a long
epic rant from both of us
about design aesthetic. But
what I was talking about
is the fact that none of us
are entitled to anything.
Any result that you see
that someone you admire got,
was just a byproduct of all
there hard work and that's it.
And sometimes there's a
byproduct of circumstances they
had no control over that were
very fortuitous for them.
I don't really want to
call it luck because yeah,
you start to show up and make the effort,
but at the end of the day,
whatever it is that you want to happen:
It's great that you want it to happen,
it's great that you're working for it,
but you can't have the
expectation that just because
you work hard, that anyone should care.
Like what's in it for them?
I think no one believes in
that anymore like, what's
in it for the other person? What are
they getting out of this interaction?
Because I think if people
thought about what's in it
for the other person when
they start something,
everything we see would be very different.
- [Karen] Yeah.
- Dramatically different.
There's entitlement now that just because
you showed up and you worked hard
or you put your heart and
soul into anything like that,
you're supposed to get something?
I ran track. Showing up and working hard
and leaving my heart on the field
still meant that I could
get tenth or twelfth place,
or as was normally the
case, second or third.
But, I wasn't entitled to that.
If someone beat me, I'm more concerned...
and here's my other thing,
if I got first place
but I was 30 seconds
slower than my last race
I was more upset. I'd
rather have the bronze
or silver or be in eighth
place and be 20 seconds faster,
than win and be 30 seconds slower.
- [Evan] Boom!
- Every time, every time.
- [Evan] Roberto Blake.
So it was a lot more fun than anticipated.
Let's see if I can find my way.
It's what, one thirty or so
in the morning Toronto time.
We kind of closed the party.
Had some good conversations,
well you can't see me I went dark.
Had a good chunk of time with Charlie
from Charisma on Command.
We had met on email
but hadn't connected in
person and so we connected,
and had some good business talk.
Him and his girlfriend
Jessica, good people.
Ended up closing down the show
talking entrepreneurship,
it's good, it's good.
A lot of the people here
are family vloggers,
not a lot of connection to what I do
but Charlie, Antonio, Roberto,
and Tim it's a good group.
I'm going to get ready for bed,
the downside was I didn't get to
say goodnight to Nina. So I missed that
I'm kind of sad about it
but we're going to have
breakfast tomorrow at eight
and then head off for a fun day of
whatever we're doing tomorrow.
So I'm back, I'm going
to put on CNN. Yeah!
(laughter)
Get ready for bed, and
I'll see ya tomorrow.